it's a it's a Monday and I'm sitting
next to mr. cutie pie himself from the
Golden Globes dressed in black
he's live here in the studio Brennan
shop get a Brennan golden Brendon Gigi
shop get out
he's Brennan Gigi shop he said this kid
has got his finger on the Hollywood
pulse of G squared U cheese squared and
you were wearing
I got g2 in in [ __ ] house writing it
up and this cutie pie with his
cauliflower ears easy was was on a round
table and he probably had stars in there
I want to know everything you got your
finger on the your kana has a beat you
kind of a list right now I'm like a poor
man's bigger version Mario Lopez that's
right you sure I don't talk like this
Brian no and I don't wear full make a
boat on and I don't [ __ ] guys hey wait
why I don't know I will be you love
Mario no but Mario Mario is all man but
you are you are more man there's no
question you big boy I don't know you
think boy hater well your big boy your
big boy you dress in black your
politically correct as [ __ ] because you
down for the cause down for the cause
ya got so many questions I can't wait
down for the cause yes but it was also I
didn't have much of an option not that I
know I know I know
not that one of wore black but you how
you but they it was suggested to you
oh no it was him suggested let's uh so
they designate you a stylist right who
we're not you know I thought about this
to us he's from London
he's this big handsome like tall dude in
which with all these celebrities gay man
or a straight man you know I can't tell
I can't tell right handsome dude though
knows his stuff we hit it off we're
dating now his name was his name's
Warren shout-out to Warren so I was
talking to him and I was like dude I
like to be loud like I like like the
loud stuff he [ __ ] fun stuff that's why
I like the peacock okay I'm like I've
liked designer suits I show him picture
my gucci boots he goes this is he goes
oh no that's all fine I bet you would
like to do that it's the Golden Globes
on if you've heard you learn all black
I went no when he was yeah
so I meet him at his office and he has
like all these suits and everything's
bad you were so excited I'm so excited
to just get to outdo the girls in color
I mean you had a warn you would have
worn lights I would look like I don't
want a siren Liberace
goddamn right oh is that a is that a
diamond-encrusted [ __ ] cape he would
over bin' sure what what award is here
for nothing just hopes like this small
after-party show amazing but yeah so I
meet with him black suit this Varvatos
suit which I love all the designer talk
and then he owes you have to go black
back I go back everything that's weird
now I look like a bouncer I don't want
wear all black and then he's like I
don't know man
so then I thought about in that day at
it later that day affecting like hey let
me wear white shirt underneath and then
spark up the socks in the pocket he
sparked something let me spot let me get
some smarty sweat let me paint some
rhymes come on man and then he said the
reply back from me I was like absolutely
not everyone for me he's wearing all
black that's it because it's it's not a
it really wasn't about the fashion right
because no it's about politics so much
for E but your employee of E and they
are yeah but I get it you know it's that
you know the it's not a fight you want
to have no but it's it's not about me my
fashion like it's like this little least
of them some people like Rose McGowan
tweeted all you I hate this Hollywood
fakery and the pig monster and she says
to Meryl Streep the greatest actress
ever
you were happy to work for the pig
monster and and and a war I accept your
awards but they're all turning on each
other it's like hey Meryl Streep didn't
know he was like Meryl Streep is just
doing her job
yeah I mean everybody was working nobody
knew exactly what was going on it's
that's a lie and and also we don't have
to attack Meryl Streep now I'm just
gonna attack me would they want to do
better
yeah yeah I love you Asia Argento or
Asia Argento sign that petition to get
[ __ ] what's-his-name Mayer uh what's
his name Roman Polanski oh that's right
you know freed and he raped anyway I
know so I mentioned I mentioned Kevin
Spacey cuz
they go is there anything you want to
talk about in particular on the show I
went Seth Meyers for 100 cents that's my
I think is a toughest job of the night
yes he has to like try to be funny but
still bring up everything that's going
on in the culture all that stuff I said
he is by far the hardest job and so I
was interesting how his jokes would
worked out and a lot of them hit and
some you know some were whatever but he
definitely did well here the hardest job
and then I said I think everyone like
Seth Meyers monologue except for Kevin
Spacey and there one kind of gets tight
yeah I get tight I'm like geez man it's
become this weird thing where Hollywood
of course has to swing when there was
one Oscars when all they would talk
about was global warming yeah and and
Hollywood there's no balance it's got to
be like everybody now is an absolute
oven Oscar yes everybody puritan over
here like sexual harassment and sexual
assault we're all against it yeah no
[ __ ] yeah we're all against it but
everybody's got it becomes this mob
mentality which always rings a little
false it feels like you know people are
like I'm they they're fat and they eat a
lot and then then all of a sudden they
just go I'm not I'm going on a diet and
they become like these insanely strict
vegans I yeah they become diagnosises
and then they lose a bunch of weight and
then they get it all back again and I
don't think this kind of solitary you
know this this fanaticism this sort of
like well there's there's a different
there's some people who or who are like
nah this needs to stop like you'll get
people like Oprah and like Reese
Witherspoon like you some people are
down for the cause yeah and you're not
getting an inch with them and there's
some people are just like it's the thing
to do I'm gonna do it you know and
they're gonna phase out but there's some
people where yeah you don't know okay
like let's take you and I I know you
very well you know me very well you know
that if we were working in an office and
a woman was being actually like she
didn't want to come to work because a
dude was just making her feel like yeah
weird we wouldn't like that we might
talk to the guy we're not down with that
okay we don't do that we don't bully
people we don't believe in that kind of
thing I will start a GoFundMe forever
yes no but but but we we'd help out
somehow
right and and and that's how I feel most
of the decent people in the world are
cuz we don't want to see a [ __ ] but I
think that's how Hollywood is most of
them are doing they're like yeah we
don't get down with this yeah I go to a
big time Human Resources guy who runs a
studio okay like a huge studio and he is
the in charge of Human Resources
so he's in charge of all the complaints
and he said something really interesting
I had dinner with him and he said that
because there's a politician in
Sacramento I was actually in trouble
because he hugs people too often and now
he's annoying but get easy so Noah
there's another right there's another
guy who never touched any women he's
married with four kids he's a good
politician but I guess he had a bunch of
he has a lot of young female interns
he's always hugging them no he doesn't
touch them what he does is he's had
conversations with him about their
dating life and that is actually
something that he may have to retire
over so I know they should retire double
strange but I talked to a state size I
have to say I've skeptical HIPAA lies
for sure how old is he he's 50 that's a
little weird but but she'll lose his job
right that's what simple but there was a
state senator from Sacramento there who
was saying he was saying it's getting
nuts for sure because you know what you
think you right now right now we're in
the middle of the the fire so anything
that happens people are good people are
actually now the the guy who sees all
these cases and is responsible for
making decisions
he runs the human race he said he said
look he said a lot of the [ __ ] is real
and then there are things in the Middle
where it's kind of so 20% you go 25% you
got [ __ ] out there yeah and and we
look at the evidence and we're like this
guy's an [ __ ] you have a real case
here yeah that guy's got to go then
there's like about like 50 percent or
whatever in the middle where you know
it's like they don't lose their job
because it's just too gray man there's
like what really happened what's going
on there's not enough evidence yes and
they don't lose their job in this huge
studio and then there's the like 20% on
the other extremity thing though
that guy's not breaking no but but but I
mean but I mean it's something that you
contend with now what he said is in our
company that 50% don't lose their job
there are they're uncomfortable we don't
realize there's been one accusation can
get you but a lot of times there's
pressure and stuff like yeah we've
talked about to her blue in the face
yeah but yeah so anyone saying what at
the gold security outgoing Globes I
almost missed my my stuff because you
had rehearsal the day before at the
Beverly Hilton and they give you like
these these huge laminate passes yeah
and they they give you assistant right I
don't have a system that like jimmy meet
you there right well they give you they
take care of everything while you're
there and she goes all take your pass
that's one less thing for you have to
worry about I'm like I don't need it
like now you're good I'll think make
sure you're gonna Mike all right so then
they picked me up yesterday and we're
headed there and they shut off Wilshire
and Santa Monica Boulevard shut down
shut it down okay she ain't getting in
there with a rocket there's cops there's
special forces guns there's a logs
there's tanks well I've never seen
anything like I've never seen me like
you and I'll see you I went well if some
were to blow up the Beverly Hilton
entertainment so over it's over
protecting that thing like it's over
that's like the Pope was oh yeah like
100 Pope's right yeah that's how they're
protecting me you know what and it's
true he didn't let me in
you took me damn near two hours to get
in because the guy was like where's your
pass and the limo drivers came I'm
dropping Brent Strom off he worked for
me because I don't care if you don't
pass I can't a union that's not zero
tolerance so I'm like uh what are we
gonna do so he's like hold on went
around like doesn't matter when you guys
go I'm a fan mint doesn't matter no
doesn't matter doesn't matter I call dia
to have someone come out and meet us
yeah whose brutal man well you figure
how dogs sniffed the car oh yeah a car
came in the car came in the car and then
they went to my luggage and then they
had mirrors that they scrolled
underneath the car what the [ __ ]
you had the rocks in there I get it in
there your next president you can't you
can't Oprah talked about that too you
can't have it would be the ultimate
target land the award goes to kaduche
you know okay what a terribie terrible
so the payments over my buddy my buddy
Frank wrote Oh
that his buddy who is a the owner of an
agency had his clients at his house and
he said dude if somebody had like come
in with a machine gun or whatever the
business would have to start over like
the time I had the Golden Globes no this
was at his certain concentrations of
stars that we're where it'd be like oh
well then Golden Globes it's like riders
we act to be no business you're screwed
you screwed up three stunts yeah start
from square one right screw all of us
guys in the home wanna watch this don't
know all the B and C this actors like
yes who you met and who looked amazing
who didn't look so amazing you want my
surprise I want your surprise my
surprise first of all was there honey
was there anybody you were not bigger
than will The Rock The Rock The Rock is
bigger than you or as you know who's not
small Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman is six
I've spent time with you said these six
three secure he I'm gonna give him six
four he's the same height as me
yeah thinner thinner better-looking ah
good will smoke and a talented son of a
[ __ ] oh my god have you seen his new
movie did we sing dance he's on he's a
Broadway singer dancer level Broadway
level showed up for the Tyson fight back
in the day in fact I was with Frank
Grillo Gavin O'Connor he shows up
looking fantastic a charming funny with
four men who were in his musical who
were probably the best looking men in
the world
gay is not the word yeah it's not the
word they were they they lived they both
they all had a bag of dicks in there I
mean it was incredible beautiful man yes
and so gay and I was like I think he's
gay but he's not he's not mates so no
you get that twisted that gauge
super-talent yeah just triple threat
yeah - sings he was good-looking
the rocks big Chris Hemsworth he's
begging me well holler he's a giant
Viking adder lookin guy better dressed
although I didn't like he had open
collar like his [ __ ]
take it easy paper button it up Chris
Hemsworth's is better follow me he's
taught me inch more shredded and might
be the best boxer fizzle in this room -
I've seen him box you know I've heard
that from other boxers god damn it mmm
that in peace and he's like seven kids
amazing dad he does yeah I make you feel
bad about yourself lying okay he's also
Thor and he's Thor so six three stalling
me man and maybe I choose on I think
that's a [ __ ] I'm giving him six
five yeah [ __ ] you hey man hey Internet
his brothers the Liam six three for sure
yeah yeah um Chris Hemsworth taller my
so my surprise pic that I think we
surprised you guys I thought was
absolutely gorgeous in person and I've
never been that big of a fan ever and
she you know who knows why she well bike
because her dad owns the hotel Pearson
Hilton Paris Hilton Paris Hilton someone
goes oh that sisters like oh look
there's Pearson cuz there's all this
commotion I'm like what I'm looking like
what gorgeous really I'm not even I'm
not a very skinny that's why I've seen
her a couple times gorgeous man she was
just she looked great I gotta give it up
you know you're the dumb things in half
right here he's way smarter than people
give her credit for
I think she's engaged now she did it
right her ring looks like a frickin yeah
yeah it looks like a oh wow there you go
who don't yeah I got you on that no I
saw up or something oh all right mmm and
then what's that I can't remember name
the group Suicide Squad played the
Margot Robbie Margot Robbie that's her
can I see her can you we're not the same
species no she's an avatar I was sitting
next door a good-looking kid so don't
don't say Oh Syd not this I've sitting
next to her while we were waiting for
our cards to pick us up I was like oh oh
that's impossible it's very it's very
rare I get nervous around anybody
you see I sure did I look combo with it
she is you tell you peach
tell you I said I got this 50 year old
friend yeah all right yeah he's rias's
he's got two kids and whites and
psoriasis let's forget about all that
but he's funny and it's teeth of
crookedness [ __ ] even though he's
Invisalign it's a nice dog see yeah but
listen
that forget all that I'm depressed in
Tesla I'm depressed dude and I have a
good I have a good and I'm just
depressed don't compare yourself oh yeah
I decided comparison is a bad thing
compare where you've come from where
you've come yes she she is simply
delicious her I Tonya movie where she
plays Tonya Harding amazing huh you know
I've hung with Tonya Harding
do you know that no I spent some time
with Tonya Harding spent some time with
her and because I used to do this show
called world's dumbest remember that huh
okay well they'd put a camera on you and
they and you would comment on my videos
though like I know he would do it to you
and she would do it till she would they
made so much money doing that for many
of us she would come sure would
and so I'd be sitting there in the
waiting room for me to you know
sometimes they'd be backed up hold up
was it you and her on the screen
together no it was just me and her in a
room with nobody else but no bun saying
for the TV show was it like you too
like you and me with a screen behind her
or you did something together just and
there she was and she and I talked to
her for a long time about not only what
she liked her whole upbringing with
skating but also I love bringing if you
[ __ ] a Ruffy yeah I got that from her
oh my she is now and I can't wait she
lives now and when I talked to her she
was in Oregon living alone and she would
hunt and and she was in a cabin I don't
think she had a lot of money her skates
yes I don't think she had a lot of money
yeah I don't know she was there last
night she was there last night
she's reversed and I heard that I said
Tonya Harding's here and they didn't
know whether to clap or not like it was
oh it was like a delay but then I think
people saw the movie clap it was a
little bit of a delay in the sky were
you at the awards or yours outside okay
yeah like - so you'll stay outside I was
on the red carpet yeah yeah a little red
carpet you wait outside
yeah and then I can't wait I've taped
you so I'm give you give you your rating
now my favorite part of the night was
James Franco
James Franco cuz the movie he did the
disaster artist yeah we play I've seen
the guy you know he's hairy sorry so
it's a he it's a story about the guy who
weirdest [ __ ] Tommy who made they say
the worst movie of all time and he
invested all his own money in it opening
weekend it opened her over all these
theaters made like thirteen thousand as
part of the movie this is the true story
oh my god and so there he is the
disaster artist so he recreates this and
how the movie became like this cult
phenomenon because it was so bad people
they're like showings years later and
became this big thing and so James
Franco redoes this and explained story
and now all the guy ever wanted to do is
win a goal I remember this this is Tommy
wise I remember this guy yes I remember
this he had um billboards and [ __ ] yeah
number on it yes and Seth Rogen tells
that story goes beyond a billboard and I
called it up and this guy answered and
he goes and only my best friend is crazy
enough and and stupid enough to create
the film of the worst move all-time
you've got a lot what a great idea great
idea I wasn't so and so James Franco
girls if they accept his award he tells
time to come up there and this all time
he's ever wanted seen the movie makes
sense right this was whole goal and
we're he goes to jump on the mic and
jayvo easy easy man and then he reads
his stuff Oh cuz they Tommy Wiseau
wanted to do something can we say
because I heard he was stopping him from
doing it he just made his whoa what a
cuckoo bird he is Tommy Wiseau at least
he got himself up on the stage because I
did it he kind of did it we couldn't do
that James amazing [ __ ] have you ever
seen James Franco play him 280 now
him and his brother to his brother stars
in the moon oh my god
this Emma James case Sterling's my
favorite person I have to thank is the
man himself Tommy Wiseau but here comes
is a change bucket oh you know
[Applause]
19 years ago stuck in traffic from the
Golden Globes he said to his best friend
Greg Golden Gloves so what I'm not
invited I know that don't want me guy
with accent long hair so I show them I
don't wait for a Hollywood I make my own
movie I'm very happy to share this
moment with a crazy thank you so
Hollywood Foreign Press look at the poor
guy look at his oh go bad it's all he
does go back chin cuz there's this shows
him playing him it's ridiculous how how
much he sounds like don't mind the lord
did he ever let him speak did why so
ever speak no he didn't he can't have
that guy in the mic maybe go I think
when you put in playing him yeah well we
talking my is actual yeah just go just
get rid of Golden Globes need to see it
no it's fascinating be oh it is yeah oh
maybe it's angular yeah the trailer I
gotta see this
yeah I gotta see this what a brilliant
idea the [ __ ] guy just said why don't
we just really all the worst movie of
all time
okay who here can really reveal
themselves to the class anybody I go
[Music]
I've been in these classes he sends just
like
don't talk about me go to class with
anybody you know of course sharp on time
try not fall asleep everybody
am i hearing an accent oh no no what
we're doing how old are you don't wanna
Greg you're 19
yeah I just turned 14 he's so good
Jim Frank is all my favorites but man
[Music]
I can't watch movie and this is my life
not right you know we always say but
yeah house house that we've bought how
this drink look at his eyes Imus I guess
we don't you have a malevolent presence
you are a perfect villain I could see
you as Dracula Frankenstein ah
Frankenstein
I'm here oh why give them job I give
them salary understand five million
dollar on this movie Greg are you
kidding a five million dollar and they
are not grateful nobody respect my
vision
[Music]
where were you born Tommy Greg that not
part of Singh are you learn an easier
question where does the money come from
huh stop just on camera I know it's on
camera just like you wanted
where did he get the money from
[Music]
Jesus Christ I have to see this movie
take it again try to lose the accent oh
my god he's good
my God he's good so when I see something
like that as an actor III go oh that's
what acting is I forgotten so good I
forgot about that
he's so so yeah that's that's an actor
right there and that's a play is that
that Tommy guy finally at the Golden
Globes that's how he did it man
crazy story right you know James Franco
like I think goes and takes writing
classes is I think he got his degree in
comparative literature the dude is a
freak
he for education he just he was he was
taking a class at Columbia I think for
you know he does all this no he's been
doing it forever since he's a kid and
then he he got one of his big breaks was
not he had to I think is that New York
your NYU and one of the things yet to do
was a documentary they have to like
further final project and he fought
Saturday Night Live they allowed him all
access and it's come out his document
should come out but Lauren Michaels gave
him all access Sarah like the whole week
how it goes and crazy well I wonder what
happens with the guy Tommy wise out like
what what is he been doing oh bride do
do another movie those kind of people
are less those kind of people are kind
of on I think he's obviously on the
spectrum like he said he's got an autism
yeah something going on like an
Asperger's or something as Bert yeah
what's he do now um did he tweet
something chin man I remember this guy I
remember this so well this guy he had
these those words poor guy I never got
to say anything though I think 14 half
years I never give up
Wow dreams do come true that's cool
though yeah yeah I train on his belts
nah but that's whatever I just think
he's yeah he's on the spectrum right
never gave up 14 and a half years
I'm into goin globes well good for him
man
oh hell it took a while but just make
such a crazy
wow what a beautiful thing interesting
that so uh you got you got Paris Hilton
surprised you anything else hmm
not really I mean Kelly Clarkson stopped
by to talk to us she had a few glasses
of wine she had some artificial
sweetener in her pocket
all right I feel like I said something
offensive because I said some B's what's
in your pocket I went hopefully snacks
she's a bigger lady
okay those may be poor taste of my part
yeah I didn't mean it because of her
size yeah she did she does seem like
she's gotten bigger yeah she had a few
kids okay
yeah I like that when they say that
there's a couple kids
yeah well oh because my wife said that I
said she looks bigger than I don't mean
I don't want to [ __ ] make fun of
anybody cuz I'm not she also said I know
she said she's sick of being on a diet
and stuff like that she's sick of
politics and she went [ __ ] it yes I can
appreciate that you know what [ __ ] off
I'm gonna just be heavier and I'm tired
of this [ __ ]
she's already struggled with her weight
I guess yeah she always has and then she
was like trying to diet and get down and
yeah just said [ __ ] it whatever good for
her man it is powerful Steve Carell
Steve Carell everyone in black black on
black on black and then after some
people didn't know there's almost a
fight an elevator because uh this little
assistant there's like a hour wait to
get to elevate you up your rooms got a
room there and have to go change on my
suit on I have to go get my stuff
because I was gonna change out maybe go
to the after parties and so I might go
my god we're never getting anywhere and
she's like no no she's like rushing
through shaking up talent talent like
going through everybody I'm like it's so
embarrassing oh my god so we get to the
front and some guy goes the [ __ ] man
I've been waiting 45 minutes and just as
all the towns me I'm the least talented
one there it's me and then all these
actors I catch it like actors freaking
Sharon Stone's behind me so they get on
we all get on the elevator and the guy
gets on it's not [ __ ] I don't play
[ __ ] this I've waited 45 minutes I'm
down this [ __ ] elevated in my room
I've been waiting all goddamn night but
I'm like I get it I don't say anything
and then the girls like sir we need to
get more town - no [ __ ] you
and then the security's with me I can
see does some MMA training us hold on
you [ __ ] you apologize to her right now
and the guy goes [ __ ] you and it's
literally you packed elevator with all
these stars jeez and the guy goes you
[ __ ] me they'll [ __ ] you and they start
screwing off and I might have my hands
form like oh man oh so I set my stuff
down I'm like oh god I want to be like
Sharon Stone just like did you say
anything I guess yeah exactly
by the way this don't looking great take
care of this but that's your body
against mine for safety no I just the
only thing I went fellas fellas come on
man come on it's been a fun night let's
not get crazy last night crazy and then
the security guard goes this is the W
this is the last that what they do you
want to act up on last elevator this
white guy who's the tannest man you've
ever seen with their peers here goes the
last elevator look behind you and I'll
be on behind him only I'm not only I'm
not gonna do are you shivering like
jujitsu for life oh my gosh it's for
life if you go to the ground actually
the one you don't want to fight Brennen
shop in an elevator not that close
that's a problem I don't mean a thing
unless you came Velasquez you wanna
fight me I don't think that's very true
that's very true but I'm just at least
dude how about do a live show this dude
comes up you know this black dude with
braids and goes yo yo this is live this
is live he's out your mixtape X we're
seven y'all you get them and I'm like
dude get out of here and I'm like what
is happening right now and then we go to
commercial we I every ones all come to a
live TV right and then we have a
commercial and then so Neil's the one
that you people go where the [ __ ] is our
security and then the girl next to me
Nina goes [ __ ] security Brendan do
something you're [ __ ] same thing and
I went I went whoa whoa no no I'm not
gonna fight on this I went I judge
turtleneck ma listen me I said I'm not
fighting I'm
sick of this and then I told her I told
the heat I went hey if you guys I said I
don't get fired if he comes back you
want me to do something I'll put on a
show for everyone I said but you got to
promise me I'm on the next show
yes and I won't get fired or sued and
he's like no no you don't do anything
and like that's why I don't do it I need
you to start throwing your weight around
a little bit I really do
Miranda yeah I'm really tired of this
whole availa it's harder they were
touched don't do anything I need your
shoes thought I would have I need you to
be a little bit of a bully once in a
while when you got a situation like that
I need you to go like this watch oh I
needed that whoa I can't whistle like
that okay
let's figure it out figure it the [ __ ]
no carry a little pocket with so long
you touching yo y'all my man can you do
this whoa yo all right that's not okay
my god again all right yo hey no no
watch this boys I'm getting bristly we
still a Kevin Smith okay boys I'm
getting bristly alright ready boys no we
getting bristle no boys I'm about to get
prickly up in here I boys one more
movement i'ma bust on your that's not
bad boys bust up the boy sounds very
sexual I know gentlemen gentlemen
uh-uh give me that I like that one yeah
gentlemen let me show you again
gentlemen ah okay I've done it all right
gents
listen man I know you want to be a
sensitive [ __ ] look no more go double
G chance
double G I need you to throw some triple
G in there all right all right doing
this yeah I'm standing square
look you double G I'm G easy all right
Gaz but I need you I needed to triple G
I need another G on there I want you to
I want the fine and up a little bit a
little bit please gentlemen see I'm
doing that boys one more moving yeah boy
you could do this boys boys that this
keeps going
I'm gonna [ __ ] you both and in the can
in the can get in a can and oh and I can
in the cancer that might be the worst
thing you know guys Cup now if this
fight breaks out I'm gonna break it up
and then I'm gonna [ __ ] you both in the
can now they go oh boy oh boy he's
calling my will they go yes please
that's fine how about boys you keep act
like that seeing your sweaty in here
yeah it's not bad not bad I'm gonna sue
pants how you take it boys
I'm gonna rub my eye like this hey boys
put some medicine on you I put my
medicine on you I'm put some it I'll put
my medicine on you guys don't cuz you
know they're they're getting sick no no
that was not good no one sounds vulgar -
well I know boys about to about to play
some bonds you keep acting this way
I'm about to glaze some buns I'm gonna
run up on some you fellas boys I'm about
to toss a mud mask on you keep this up
what what do you think hold a man and
poo on them and do you have explosive
diarrhea god that's not good
all right man I don't know security more
we're getting security nobody's
Turnstone doesn't want you holding them
down and [ __ ] in the oven
check it out though why no one way to
get everybody out of an elevator is just
taking I got that will do do hey that's
not bad if you go hey you guys start
fighting I swear to god I'm gonna [ __ ]
oh data every breakup everything
everyone chill the [ __ ] yeah you could
kill my mom and it'd be like I'd be so
mad but if you like he's gonna [ __ ] now
I got a way to get her later yeah get a
lighter it's true that's hilarious
[ __ ] and we'll dial that situation down
while shading a shitty ghost destroy
every fall what I owe dude remember on
when we did at last fighting kid on
Thursday right
yeah we're in here I looked at you and I
was a kind is it hot in here except to
go to that member had to go to my
rehearsal well you guys didn't see this
but Brendan broke out I'm sweating like
a mother like I sweat it was like are
you what I saw
am I am i are we in a sauna and it's not
effective because you started sweating
immediately I have a health run right
now I looked at Brian I'm like dude is
that hot here like not really very
sweating like them like I'm just hot and
I leave we talked about the poor screen
broke down so I've taken over to II
which is in Studio City yeah I'm in the
Ober I'm sitting there like how did not
feel good at all
and the my I haven't told you the story
and the uber drivers this glorious black
girl and she's just bump in this trap
music she's like what my butt what what
it's so loud the windows are down she's
like why what and I'm on hey can you
pull over and she's just not listening
music so loud were down the 405 she's
going 90 she's like honey I get you
there on time so we're a little late
yeah I don't like you got to pull over
and she's not listening and I and I'm
trying to hold it I mean like yeah yeah
pull you up all over and I just go all
out the window I catch the car all over
her car and then also on my white shirt
I was wearing on my I did usually II but
I so I threw up twice at the window she
doesn't even notice she's jamming so
hard to [ __ ] will you throw a very
Thailand they did because when we did
Rogen you just went you went bah and you
just open her mouth I was silent the
only sound you heard was like here we
hear a mouth open watch I just opened my
mouth and that's all you hear so if I
throw up it's you know there's a
disaster you think somebody's dying
somebody's like who harpoon the [ __ ]
hippo and with Brendan he's goes uh-huh
and because it's like we got the
silencer you hear oh and you just hear
water hitting two trash can dude so I
couldn't believe I threw up everywhere
in that uber on uber in the Ober I'm
like thank you have a good day I get on
Mike you might wanna run through the
wash I get in to II I have like three
minutes I go into the bathroom wash my
face with cold water I look like pure
death yeah I have to button up that
jacket that suede jacket on so you can't
see the throw up and I get in there like
mammoth throw up again and this is the
first I met the whole staff and we're
going through like what we're gonna go
over and I'm trying not to throw up so
you know me I'm I talk man so they're
looking for like feedback on like
subjects and points and I don't say a
word
and I just kept going every now and then
because I've already throw-up in my
mouth
I'll just go that's amazing that sounds
good mmm that's good and you're sweating
I'm sweaty and I can tell nothing
worried like oh oh he's a drug addict oh
he's he's right drug addict right that's
what's going on in withdrawals yeah
that's what they think yeah
the small problem I have a heroin
problem is I an man with a heroin so as
soon as it as soon as we wrap I go
where's your bathroom everyone else
stays a small chat i beeline the
bathroom hurl everywhere and just leave
so I had to send them a had my manager
sent me an email like Brendan's not a
heroin addict he's just he's super sick
right now so it's from the I drink so
much coffee I figured out that night
before I drink nearly 16 cups of cops 16
and I've been averaging 12 cups of
coffee week and by the way not eating we
can't have that
yeah and I guess the acidity in my
stomach you're not a believing teenage
girl I'm not I just love being busy and
yeah so the city in my stomach
I just can't have aesthetic well so I've
got coffee in four days now like I've
the worst headache and I'm drinking
green tea right now how you communist
but check this out so yesterday on the
set they're like oh you know it's an
after party you want the vibe to be fun
you have drinks and I didn't realize
liqueurs one of the most aesthetic
things you can drink so like a gentleman
I order Mike Campari soda yeah I drink
two of them if you watch the show you
can see me drinking every now and then I
think - oh I didn't think of it thing
wraps I'm sitting like oh you're
starting to sweat again Brendan what is
going on here man and I'm like do I have
aids in my stomach what the [ __ ] is
happening to me right now I'm sweating
and then I see beautiful are you Robert
and I'm like I feel a little better but
I'm gonna throw up if she talks to me
longer yeah my car comes I've seen the
car like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna throw up in
this car now let's throw up in this car
and finally I'm like me and I'm holding
it in but I'm it's like an ab workout
but I'm sweating profusely through the
suit again and then I get out he pulls
up my house and I just grabbed the tree
and hurl every hole we might want to go
to the doctor to make sure everything's
all right but when I don't drink coffee
alcohol
III don't think you'll realize that you
and I we have to we use our body for how
we make our living right right
stand up talking and if it's off you in
trouble I can't have [ __ ] go wrong and
now take a look at my neck for a second
oh it's so bulky I was bulging there
yeah okay yeah tumor well so I knew one
of us were right go soon so he eats me
still it's red it's red and I have a I
have a seat knowledge there yeah what's
going on okay well we don't know what's
going on but I do have a doctor neighbor
and I said I have a swollen lymph node
jit neighbor yeah he's a dog there's a
doctor and I go I think I have a swollen
limbs no cuz I have you go on line and
you're like where are the lymph nodes
yeah I go and if you have a swollen
lymph no for no reason that's not good
that can be I had one as a kid cancer
yeah so um he comes over and he goes
he's looking at me he goes it looks like
a hematoma doesn't that's not it it's I
got a massage and they were went burst
the first a sack I guess who the [ __ ]
massage so he said like I dream
abdul-jabbar now slush and it's an it's
sore did she kill an eel misogynist yeah
strong woman with very strong hands got
into my neck and I remember attacks is
that what it is yeah so now what do I do
cuz I get it a great now no drag no you
got this like you I'm gonna have
cauliflower neck Livius we did I got a
Bose in the next run with some of the
stories I told you through your doctor
friend I don't want to go the doctor
right and by the way meanwhile I'm like
I don't I can't have anything cuz I have
to shoot I got the Goldbergs today
tomorrow exactly I got it I'm gonna have
to cover this can't wait till I cover my
legs my psoriasis thighs that's gonna be
hot
hey guys need an extra hour if you could
dad my size paint my leg [ __ ] problem
man I used my body I have no man my piss
I'll go with you don't have to write
good yeah I didn't have to pee it the
[ __ ] ash at home dear you I didn't have
to [ __ ] I was peeing sitting down all
right that's fair we had a guest who
came here and he came in and I'm like he
was gonna do the podcast and he just
goes he walked in I'm talking on the
bathroom thing and he just sat down I
just hear
[ __ ] you didn't give me a little
warning I'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
oh that's name here while you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like without announcing it yeah this
very strange yeah you gotta be like I'm
gonna take [ __ ] I'll kill mouths
silently in there and I know you're
comfortable we knew dropping along that
well and there's a copy home oh you
thought would come recession a celebrity
poo yeah it's not cool man cool at all
I saw that movie in sit insidious I
think it's part for you don't you don't
like scary movies right I don't mind him
oh no I saw mother now that Darren
Aronofsky movie with Javier Bardem and
what's-her-name bring that up chin
Jennifer Lawrence right yes dude if you
know what the movies about
it's wild don't soil it well the spoiler
alert is important as a scary movie yeah
so the mood the movie makes no sense
oh you walkin out though yeah no it's
out the movie makes no sense if you
watch it unless you know what you're
watching so I'm gonna say what it is
because it's people have already talked
about it but she's mother nature the
house is the world Javier Bardem is God
but they're they're married oh and then
Adam and Eve come to the house oh wow
which is Ed Harris in Michelle Pfeiffer
they come to the house and then all hell
breaks loose good movie though yeah
scary you know it's a retelling of the
Bible yeah and in that sense it's scary
you love it you don't know it um I
didn't love it but I thought it was very
very I thought it was a really
interesting idea
oh dude how about so I'm going insidious
with my girl when you do you bring food
and everyone you guys bring food in the
movies and snacks like I don't buy the
[ __ ] AMC snack so sucked
what'd you bring your own food of course
are you shooting me I'm not [ __ ]
you're a goddamn coming I buy the food
that's there oh my god are you coming
with a [ __ ] without with a with a
meal and an out burger and all that yeah
with a meal well I know well no I mean
well you can't do that well check it out
so at the Century City all have a pizza
yeah so that yeah well a hot dude so at
the Century City Mall
cross from literally the literally right
across from Lethe that's attached to it
is the greatest food court you've ever
seen let me rip these off for you
the vag appalled a yeah they have chick
fillet you use their they've Janice I
screwed you eat it there they have sushi
need have burgers you don't break
training you know great sushi sushi no
that's right alright so hold on so I get
my pole haven't eaten you know all day
I'm feeling good yeah tell him I
Chipotle I've never been stopped once
since I was a kid I bring and there's
this young kid working the front nose
you ain't bringing that in here you'll
get the [ __ ] out of here Neos dude I
can't we have outside food here you go
come on and once a who stops summer
breeze it's Julianne I don't work there
oh it's really gonna be like tell him
let's do that eighteen the cop behind
them goes like this I go so I guess
throw it away I haven't eaten all day
I brought this here bought a movie
ticket I'll go buy whatever food you
want I just want to bring this in there
two years ain't happenin I started
laughing and when I respect it man I
respect it respected job and the cop
behind them it goes the cop giant cop
that's so great yeah so I went around
the corner I packed this fat ass burrito
in my back pocket I'd the case so is my
cheap meal had my queso cheese and my
tortilla chips I packed it all down my
pants Oh minutes hide my coat real tight
and then had my drink under my armpit
and was like have a good day sir
walked right by got in the movie
theaters like thanks to me smell like
pure [ __ ] I just pulled on my [ __ ] Jesus
Christ you smell like soup now yeah I do
yeah and I laid the whole spread out
myself one nice movie I see so mad nice
movie truth the guy next to me a grown
man
smelled like pure [ __ ] man such bad Bo
drives mimamsikas out that go go gadget
nose smell like pure [ __ ] yeah and he's
drinking a Slurpee at I don't know every
bit of 47 drinking a blue Slurpee if you
drink the coke you're fine the blue you
gotta grow the [ __ ] up right touch
kids so he's drinking this and he's but
it's at the end and you will not give it
up Oh
like bro will you get a refill me I will
buy you every seven-course you shut the
[ __ ] yo you have the quieter but I'm
quiet with it habit still I'm quiet with
it that queso cheese from Japan a well
go [ __ ] your it's very delicious
well you sometimes when you sit next to
somebody on a plane if it makes you pull
out a spread they're just like ears I'm
gonna turn nice yeah like your report
that chick-fil-a I'm they're playing
everyone goes ah man that smells nice
yeah [ __ ] I don't want you when it's
curry no if it won't see well there's
see you're not used to smuggling food
into movie theaters or playing or plans
because there's rules to this game it's
like baseball it's unspoken rules no
Mediterranean okay
no fish no sushi no cab no fermented
cabbage no no no no no no sauerkraut if
you're gonna have a bratwurst hot dog
can have sauerkraut okay matter of fact
be careful with your spicy mustard
correcting guns that can smell all right
thank you can have regular yellow cat
don't plant smells like a burp correct
yeah so there's the Chinese food depends
where you get it from
panda we're cool with this lame outside
panda my friend post lady is is
literally on a plane and she's blasting
I wish I could find a Korean lady
blasting was music and I'm like is she
[ __ ] kidding me and I look at her and
she's got earphones in and she thinks
she's listening to it i hear oh because
that plug did i realize what's going on
everybody's going like this is she
kidding me and finally this stewardess
goes excuse me and she goes yeah thanks
you guys yeah the music she goes yeah
and I go you have to plug it in a loud
as [ __ ] my god she thought she was
listening there
I had a nice time at the movies man it's
all insidious ate my meal gentlemen see
the problem with insidious in with other
moves I don't need the monster there the
evil spirit spoiler if you haven't seen
it I don't mean spoiler again you have
three two one all right you're in there
now
I don't need a demon to die at the end
or be conquered at the end it's
okay if you leave it scary as [ __ ] it's
okay if someone dies in it and because
these built this old lady just keeps
[ __ ] tearing through all these demons
yeah she's not that's not scary right is
she
no she's also 22 it's not wanted to the
beginning of forest areas [ __ ] threes
amazing twos great I think once why the
worst one but they're scared
I want scary doesn't have a nose yeah
that's that's the main demon in this I
don't like that guy yeah he's pretty
scarce fingers or keys keys yeah there's
a problem now how would I fight that
demon your mom no no nope you wanna
again spoiler alert for insidious four
and three two one Desai beat'em your mom
gives you a whistle whenever you're
scared and in the after underworld if
you find that whistle and you blow it
your mother comes who he killed and
kills him for you I said spoiler alert
you guys would be pissed at me I said
[ __ ] spoiler alert four times now
okay the ending was so stupid I felt
like they rushed through it what if I
rebuild up is so legit I was like damn
it's legit scary movie yeah I'm pretty
scared right now can I ask you this and
I am knuckled when I say this I am
knuckle deep in queso cheese I'm talking
give me enough I don't get enough I paid
for a side of queso and chips you give
me this little [ __ ] size frenzy I put
you in a cheese ah God you wanted more
it's so nice man they do the case so so
right there
I don't give a [ __ ] all right but let me
ask you like queso no but let me ask you
this I appreciate that I appreciated
your knuckle deep because I can see you
being that way and I get it and I love
the tortilla chips it settles my stomach
now that demon i watch the erudite demon
scary but those teeth are waiting to be
knocked out so if you were to punch that
stupid demon in his [ __ ] mouth yeah
and those teeth were like down his
throat
that would hurt break its teeth doubt
hurt now does it bother you you and him
have the same teeth does that bother you
at all guys your bottom teeth are just
like his top weights does that bother
you in the least bit I feel like you're
being a little unfair I don't know if I
really not sure you don't think you have
the same like brow why well I don't like
writing forehead I don't like what you
did with that and I
you did with this just now but I do see
some resemblance yeah it's not a big
deal yeah my nose is different your nose
is completely different their gums I
have different gums but and I have the
same bags on my eyes at this lady on the
left but it's not big deal
yeah we're both kind of dying yeah my
stomach's Delfina yeah I know you two
mine your neck huh
so anyway this is the last part okay
thank you so much guys oh I started
GoFundMe yeah we do some critter mats
hold up let's catch up with MJ MJ's been
gone six weeks yeah let's hear it let's
hear about how was your European trip
this amazing thank you so much what you
thinking us
well yeah you give me the time off so I
missed last week's episodes what all did
you do I went to three different
countries you flew in to where
originally flew into Amsterdam and then
spent the night there just one night in
Amsterdam in the city and then it's time
to join you on Christmas Eve is legal
cool sorry
yeah and then we seed in this windmill
converted Airbnb house here yeah yeah it
was super creepy that was like con with
a windmill so like the first level it's
cool super cozy nights were you like
cook and updating yeah and then he the
guy named Hans shows the tour
yeah and so the second level is where
you sleep and it's kind of cool and then
also in the third level is just dolls
like straight just dolls and then
there's this like crib where the doll
sitting up like Annabelle style and then
there's like this cross behind her and
like everything's in Dutch like super
creepy and then has a baby that you can
rock with it you weren't kidding
oh no and then there's no way he laid
out there's candy laid out and it's open
and there's more dolls and right above
it there's like these like dress with a
little bit of like stains questionable
stains did us music oh I just you know
just got at a thrift store
oh wow I literally thought we were gonna
die like first of all how many of you
are there there's me my best friend
Paige and then it was her stepdad and
then her stepmom oh okay so we're all
going through this tour like oh my God
we're gonna be chopped up and hidden
underneath this and this is it like this
is this huh me to go out yeah and sounds
like hostile super super creepy like
every
was just laid out and then he's like oh
yeah you can you want to touch her I was
like hell no no night there we stayed
two nights there you smoked weed with
the pants no just a joint in Amsterdam
no I said the Dutch are the tallest
people with the exception of the
Sudanese super tall oh you're wondering
I'm glad you touched now all but do you
guys do any other drugs in Amsterdam no
that was that was only one you said you
go to all read history yeah we went to
the red light is only got a dick son no
but I got in trouble because her brother
was like take a photo like you're not
supposed to do that that's no and so
he's like pushing me against the wall
and this girls like dancing like this
I'm like no you're not do that super hot
there's really hot one this super super
hot and that this is so weird because I
heard we got enough you find kid live in
Ansan
I don't hey what do you it looks like
you're looking for you're looking for
the date no it's official no it is yeah
tell Amanda oh yeah I should tell Joe
yeah all right live Anson all right all
right we've been allowed to take any
pictures of the girls dancing no I
thought that was a good known thing I
thought you know that oh I guess so and
so he's like taking photos all sudden
this like little girl she looks like she
just got four cuz she's full makeup has
a big bag of probably like her little
stripper clothes comes out screaming at
us threatens to take the phone which the
phone is my phone that he took from my
hands I was like freaking out but that
was only a little trouble we got in good
food out there good food well it was
everything was like planned honestly I
just steal a bottle of hot sauce from
like a Hard Rock Hotel really and then
took it everywhere with me
where'd you go to local restaurants who
you went to we went to local so my
friend Paige her boyfriend she met him
in Amsterdam in February so we had like
a traditional Dutch dinner on Christmas
there are they dutch are they her family
enough she grew up in Australia her
parents live in Kazakhstan because her
stepdad
this is from Texas yeah works for
Chevron and they live in Kazakhstan but
her mom's from New Zealand chefs a real
melting pot one it was crazy and her
real dad lives in China and his
girlfriend lives in Japan so they flew
out for Christmas dinner it was a crazy
a global city one night man stand then
where'd you go and then we stayed in the
wind meal which was like outside
yeah excuse me in Holland but outside of
tall people huh so on Christmas Day
they're all waking up late and I wanted
to go to one of the churches because
everything's beautiful
like all old school yeah so I'm gonna go
catch like a service their bikes there I
couldn't even get over like I got short
legs like I'm five five but I'm like
torso I'm trying to like strangle I
could not get over this bike and so they
come out it's like a kid's bike and I
had a ride like a clown like my knees
are going to my chest all the way in the
rain it's not made for medium-sized
people no it was like literally this
tall bird I couldn't ride the Dutch bike
my feet wouldn't touch the pedals so I'm
writing all through the rain please the
eye to eye with a lot of people there
and you made it - I made it to the
service how was it I didn't know
anything they're saying but I knew some
of the songs so I could like hum along
yeah but that's just a hard language
isn't it yes super weird yeah just so
then one night so then then where'd you
go from there so from there we flew to
Prague supercool yeah it was nice it was
like a time machine it was buried in the
war
why was Prague so how's your favorite I
was kind of mean there that was only
time Romanian hello they were brewed a
little bit I got almost pickpocketed in
Amsterdam but that was another thing
then Prague I were just different it was
just yeah so my buddies got got worked
over in Prague really yeah yeah they
went to a club and these women were
beautiful and they were they were
sitting with them and stuff like that
and they kept ordering these blue drinks
and then the bill came the bill was like
$2,000 they dipped out on and they go we
didn't or these and a couple of rough
looking like cheque service you did big
boys like you came on pages and they
were like hey buddy yeah Japan you guys
American your hand
where'd you go from there MJ from Prague
we flew to Krakow Poland cuz her her
pages grandma
survived the Holocaust she was polish
but she was a worker yeah cuz she was
both so they didn't she because she
wasn't Jewish
yeah cause she wasn't Jewish and so then
we went to Krakow and then we took a
two-hour ride to Auschwitz
so Krakow you
right I think you're gonna tell me
that's many of the concentration camps
where a lot of the Jews were killed
yes were in so Krakow was one Treblinka
Dachau and then outfits they often yeah
and over it it says work will set you
free
yep we did the whole tour it was reduced
knowing what we did pretty interesting
to do it was heavy
it was super heavy experience so that's
why I'd like to do that yeah I mean I
was freezing and it was snowing I could
imagine and I was bundled up I wore like
three jackets I was wearing like two
pairs of pants and I was freezing I
couldn't feel my toes I could only
imagine when they just wear their little
jumpers and happen my naked my friends
grandma she was crazy she her brother
died in her arms at a concentration camp
outside of Auschwitz and then her mom
died and they put this blanket over her
mom as almost like a ceremonial you know
and then they're so cold there to steal
the blanket back from her mobbed up
mom's dead body yeah yeah super case you
spend the night there yeah and the
honestly like Auschwitz was like it's
like a going to zoo and like you know
how it doesn't feel right like it feels
like something's wrong it's like that
times a thousand its it was the lowest
level of human depravity you know the
ultimate I mean I don't know how many
how many Jews hundreds of gypsies gay
people how many people were
systematically children were put in
ovens and put in gas chambers yeah they
had shot they had all the hair bundles
in this huge room of all like the
victims and I we went to the gas
chambers where like it even says please
be quiet and it's respect they're
suffering because thousands of people
have died in this room I recommend
anyone to do this to see was the
craziest thing and then they would have
other Jews pull the bodies out and a lot
of times they were like 14 year old kids
and they'd be back you have to Paul
about his out there because we then they
put and they tell you to go in there and
they tell you we're gonna take a shower
there's no sometimes they would though
yeah they didn't know yeah because David
also was also a work camp what else did
you do and then from there we went back
to Krakow spent a new year in Krakow
which is pretty cool because it's it's
really updated kind
vibe up there every other stores liquor
store which because everyone's drinking
and it was just a fun time and I've
everyone thought I caught a fish a lot
of the fans thought I caught a fish
because we're we were drinking packing
up more beers
and one of the liquor stories and
there's a stuffed animal and I was like
hey like long day at sea and all the
fans like you finally went fishing like
I just posted that bar like 20 minutes
ago yeah oh my god I'm in Cracow so I
didn't go fishing
good to know good fishing yet it was
good we eat a lot of pro guys it was
just like meat and cheese and bread
that's pretty much everything I'm not
mad at that yeah you'd have been happy
and so then we took a drive to zakka
pony which is the ski town and along the
way there's this little cheese hut house
where they he'll make cheese berries and
honey and the lady's name is babushka my
mother yeah so she she we bought a bunch
of jams and stuff from her there and we
went to Zach a pony for a night for our
last night and then our driver picked us
up the next day and we were supposed to
go to back to Krakow and from cacao to
Amsterdam the connecting flight from
Amsterdam to LAX so a two-hour drive
from Zak a pony turned into a five and a
half hour drive because there was a
festival I guess the day before we
missed the festival we're only there for
New Year's Day not New Year's Eve and
we're freaking out because that's the
only flight we're looking at their
flights there's no other flight and then
we miss that flight that we missed our
flight from Amsterdam to LAX I'm C I'm
gonna come back to the cheese berries
and honey I'm thinking about stop think
I've been thinking about your tummy you
have to so we're like looking at options
the only option was we're going to rent
a car and then take a car all the way
through Germany to am drive de mer and
draw and drive no it's gonna be a pain
in the ass we have to come up through
the Arctic over to Alaska oh my god
that's gonna be a [ __ ] do you have sled
sleds for the wheels sled dogs good
here's the good news and bad news Nikki
I'm gonna pull your bar across the door
oh so you made it tall
so we're calling the airport like hey
there's like four of us we got to go
like please stop the flight and like
sorry we can't the gates already closed
so there's stopped traffic we run out
mid traffic running through with all our
luggage in the rain to the airport but
they're like sorry the gates closed I'm
like no no please it's like it's like
dude like look you can do carry-on souls
like [ __ ] I have to like throw
everything so I'm like wrapping Lulu's
around my neck and then I had to dump
out all the honeys all the vodkas I
brought back for everybody like
everything my friends like yeah I left
like shoes behind there's literally
trails of all my clothes I'm sorry did
you get that coat though now goats sweet
Thanks
no I knew made it on the plane made it
on the plane you took the bag that your
ship was in and just had to throw just a
backpack I left everything there so some
Lulu's got left behind she's made it I
had a few around my neck but made it
through and there was a Haitian guy who
was they said you can't bring all this
stuff and he had obviously had a
suitcase full of stuff to bring to his
family and hey my mother is amazing my
mother's a amazing person and the guy
was having to just take out like he was
bringing back shampoo and the thing
because you know he's like bring you
liquids on the plate like if they're
there there wasn't he had over done his
weight he had three suitcases yes in
there right now and he was a poor man
who had bribed when obviously when to
bring stuff back to my mother my awesome
mother said to him I'll ship it give me
all of this and I will ship it to you
and you know what he said it'll never
get to them they'll take it at customs
yeah and and I helped him I remember
helping him pull all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
happen no and then I I took it and I
said I'm gonna throw this away and I'm
gonna go buy it again and I'll throw it
away just for spite don't be from Haiti
so that's just a feel-good song yeah
yeah I was like be American next time
don't be American Toby Haitian and so
you know what you do on your little
break by training with Manny Pacquiao
and training from knuckle Sichuan
they're a little red now aren't they
yeah did you train what no I swear jab
what did you do this weekend days before
anything Cheesecake Factory now how many
people are you killing who'd you go to
cheesecake with - friends - friends
hey only one came back to two human
friends - even a few humans hung out
with two humans it's the one over here
to you by Marina del Rey right but in
that general area
I still live across there yeah yeah
nice-looking place yeah sure it is
cheesecake so amazing place it's just
the weird kind of complex random like
biggest many versions Egyptian are and
get everything wrong yeah did someone
did a breakdown of it's hilarious own
who's involved in the development of it
did a whole breakdown how it doesn't
make any sense
and now the menus made to make you
confused it's on purpose really it's a
book it's a Bible it's like they do it
well doctor they do some I've had very
good meals me too me too
yeah me too Syracuse at midnight by
myself not sad at all uh you some kind
of engine yeah
oh we need we own oh we did there might
what no nothing okay all right
this one is Cris cyborg and Jason pearl
oh I saw it I haven't seen that people
have been finding this like crazy and at
first someone else had the video then
Chris eventually posted on her Instagram
so I'll just let you watch it
oh yeah
he just says be ready and then he just
smacks her on the face super hard have
you ever seen McSweeney slap me no
youtube McSweeney slaps Rena job before
swine they smacked me before so is that
a common thing these yeah not really
I don't suggest it either no cyborg is a
badass bot from tough days so I don't
know if they're gonna have it probably
not
I'll google it during yeah you flash but
uh he's slapped like he's like you ready
to push me push me and then he just goes
he bows and slaps they'll pass out a
magnet I feel like that wouldn't work
for you I don't know back in the day so
it really didn't question we're just
trying to figure it out you know but I I
think cyber got slapped harder how is
that doesn't wanna make sense the US
auto on with lyoto machida way back in
the days and that Japanese wrestler guy
and he slaps the odo like three four
times I guess famous for it yeah he's
like Oh honor people's line up and get
smacked that's it look like yeah that
gosh Chris I were just an animal what
else yet yeah all right
Indian man who went to his friend's
wedding got captured by a woman's family
there and got held at gunpoint to marry
her because what he raped her or
something no it just it was a random
kidnapping of this guy that was at a
wedding and then uh they forced him to
marry he was crying during the ceremony
and they were holding a gun point to his
head so there's like you're marrying
this girl yeah they just grabbed there's
more to the story well I feel like he
probably raped her and they're gonna and
they said you're gonna [ __ ] marry
they're gonna invest they're
investigating right now but the guy was
literally crying and you could see a
little bit here sounds like he was he
had done some [ __ ] engineer or maybe
because he has a [ __ ] together the force
of my marriage
yeah was kidnapped and forced to marry a
woman at gunpoint in Bihar the video
clip from the wedding shows Vinod Kumar
dressed as a groom being thrashed and
forced to perform wedding rituals in
Patna spond Rock area it can be seen in
the video that a group of women
allegedly from the bride's family tried
to convince him to cooperate as he begs
to be released
we are only performing your wedding not
hanging you bride's relatives are heard
singing in love with you so that's
pretty much it yeah I really didn't want
to get man I think it sounds like I bet
you you're gonna find out that he he
raped her or had another fit and they
forced her another so that's
traditionally traditionally you have a
dire you marry the person right so there
was always that that that they would
make you marry the woman that you they
still do that [ __ ] and this is backward
[ __ ] man the thing that lady said is the
family of saying like we're just
marrying you we're not we're not kidding
are not killing your dad that's the only
way that makes sense
yeah like dude we we could do the all
tonight oh you're right we're just
forced you to marry us yeah you're lucky
and him crying he knows you know it's it
makes sense to him in a weird way that's
interesting question yeah epidemic since
yeah
that's why the males in the family put a
gun to his head and go okay [ __ ]
you're going to marry her that actually
makes a lot of sense yeah that's what
I'm pretty sure sucks for that for the
because remember I don't like alright
you made us do do rape me and now he's
crying there's no words those rural
communities if she gets raped then no
one wants to touch right and it's
dishonorable same reason why they put
acid on your face - yeah so you're
marrying her that's what you did bro
Thanks so that guy Jake Paul is just an
update I'm sorry I Jake ball Logan Paul
you know how he did that video that
everyone didn't like yeah well yeah so
I'm not starting Chris D'Elia when we're
at the comic store about this because
Chris has just been [ __ ] trash and
Logan Paul right which is hilarious he
just took on the whole army he's like
you shut the [ __ ] up that Chris doesn't
care and I went but dude II did
and Criseyde he's known for like the
reason why I like you as I get what
you're saying cuz you don't know
anything about I don't [ __ ] about
because no he's dumb for doing stuff
like this is his first offense like he
purposely went there to film this he's
purposely doing this stuff drives me
nuts so now [ __ ] this guy was go ahead
so this thing called we are unicorns we
the unicorns made this collaboration
video of a collage video of him in Japan
and look what he does here I just got to
be careful to not like disrespect the
culture Japan is all about gotta be
careful to not like disrespect the
culture Tokyo is a real-life cartoon
what he do know how it is in Japan
they're all about the respect we're
gonna be respectful yeah look they just
got loaves and brown just the whole
thing was the issue this one is just for
a display oh we're gonna be respectful
Vic gameboy color how much so he's a
dick oh he's a tool yeah
the game seems to be malfunctioning
macho broken though Wow
Toyota iQ anyways the budget follow this
guy younger kids were like seven to like
twelve loved him why they like even buy
his merchandise I don't know it's a
terrible is outrageous all he was talk
about it oh man he just seems what he
seems like is not a bad person he seems
super immature ignore holdin ieaving
that daddy's do that's that's it but he
also seems it's just ignorance and
immaturity and clumsy humor you know
that's it that's what it feels yeah it's
him trying to be outraged he's on scene
that tells me it's like the boring after
the either yeah like Borat that was
talent like that was talent yeah and and
very offensive but also they talented he
was very funny this is a clumsy you some
people are just clumsy and not that
funny
and he's 22 and trying to come up with
contrary yeah it's awful and and I think
that when you take a bunch of little
things like that and put them together
you know if you didn't have that huge
fallen and he really says pretty good he
ain't the first guy to do it sees I saw
plenty of you know I've been to lots of
different countries I've seen plenty of
tourists behave that way and worse so
it's a bummer oh yeah alright yeah I was
never on his train but I definitely
won't defense oh I've been to Japan and
Japan is is a very very one of the
biggest influences a lot of people in a
very small area so they tend to be very
polite so protocol and being polite and
quiet is really important remember that
because Japan had typhoons and typhoons
come in and devastate everything yeah
it's an island so they would make their
houses you ever wonder why the houses
were made from paper like the walls are
made from paper well the reason for that
is that if that
foon hits and your house falls in on you
if it's made of brick and mortar and
stone you die yeah so that was one of
the reasons but the problem is that when
you have separations wall separating you
made of paper you can hear everything in
the other room I have an art called they
practice the art of not listening so if
you hear somebody having sex or having
an argument in the next room yeah it's
very important man yes man yeah manners
and silence and and all those things
about Ward are very important so when
you have an American coming in going
they're just like dude you know this is
not how we do things
here's thrown like dead fish and octopus
around twos yeah why clumsy indeed he's
he'll learn his lesson that's how young
dumb kid the little brown though he's
the people former young and dumb to
thought they don't they're like out
whatever man people are just trying to
suppress them hold him down man we can't
have any fun I think he probably has
heard this backlash right I don't think
so I don't think really know he'll be
bigger from this his father
yeah his followers will they're gonna
rally behind he's gotten a lot of heat
for this some same stream people though
well ours and stuff right I wonder not
from now crew though like other you to
it's like it seems he's in a different
Lane you know like he doesn't he's not
trying to have a show on Fox he's not
trying to do you think it won't his
sponsors he's got big sponsors so a lot
of his sponsors are shine away maybe
yeah Disney he had coke he had a lot of
big sponsors he had is Inc oh yeah yeah
I think if you look at his cheeks Jake
they had Disney but then they cancelled
with Jake is he was causing too much of
ruckus in his channel - yeah he's
causing too much trouble ya know the
suicide video a lot of his big sponsors
yeah have you heard their music there's
a Jake Paul that has music his brother
yeah yeah it's terrible yeah it's really
good my friends kids were just blast I'm
like can you please turn this off it's
so bad it's so rad yes yes chin I don't
know if you guys talked about this
already but Trump's tweet about the
nuclear bomb button you know what Scott
Baio said about Trump know he goes can
you guys remember he's from New York and
in New York this is all you [ __ ] do
all you do and you're from Queens
when you're from Brooklyn is to take the
like basically boss people's balls so a
lot of him is just you just doing yes
sanction and other pressures are
beginning to have a big impact North
Korea soldiers are dangerously fleeing
to South Korea
Rocketman now wants to talk to South
Korea for the first time perhaps that is
good news perhaps not we will say all
right and there's actual tweets right
there
well someone from his depleted and food
starved regime please inform him that I
do have a new kill button but it is much
bigger I'm more powerful than his and my
button works sorry sometimes he cracks
me the [ __ ] up he's just being a New
Yorker right now and I think that's
funny well yes a nuclear bomb all right
so this woman was reported missing on
Saturday her name's Courtney Rowland
she's reported for a Texas A&M and even
Dana White and other people the real big
people started tweeting and
instagramming about her her missing
status and she turned up today and it
was weird
so she was she was found underneath a
bridge a bridge and her car was at a
Galleria and then uh her belongings were
where like a chick-fil-a or something
and so this woman she tweeted or not
tweeted she messaged her friends saying
like I'm being followed by someone in a
truck and then once that happened she
disappeared for what two days now and
then they just found her underneath a
bridge add that she's alive she's alive
and she's all good they're taking her to
the hospital just to get her checked out
we don't know no idea exactly no did
they steal the chick-fil-a hey hey man
I'm trying to get all the fam you go
back to the page you're on before this
one can you just click on Emily rata
ciao okay I want to make sure that
everything is okay with her no I just
want to make sure everything is oh wow
all right with her yeah now I just
wanted to know if everything mom okay is
that who's that is yes
um Radha yeah all right she's she's
doing already
congratulations is what eyes at least
she's wearing black and I wanted to make
sure that she was in solidarity
I met her in her black um put some but
there's no update or anything chins now
as far as I saw I mean just went missing
a truck and then she and she had huge
celebrities like Dana White and some
whatever Peter King is the guys on
computer King is he's the the guy of
Sports Illustrated okay I guess that's a
huge celebrities Dana White and Peter
King all huge followings I guess she got
kidnapped or something or she had a it
seems like an episode of paranoid
schizophrenia like drugs or something
like that ladies like somebody's
following me and then kind of went off
on a binge yeah but it's weird she'd be
a report and I was [ __ ] together like
that
very weird it's hard to be schizophrenic
can be a reporter I would imagine like
it just hit yeah I like it just freaked
out people like did they ever like
unpack what happened I woman who was
kidnapped by them by the Romanian mafia
that was all fake it was often covered
on here brother turned up nobody there
no but I came out yeah she got yes she's
getting sued oh she came out yeah they
follow fake yeah she was the whole deal
they're really hot yeah yeah but with
heard that she just disappeared her
family has worked you know freaking out
about it her friends and then suddenly
she just something fishy Gonder and
under a bridge
an overpass hmm we shouldn't update you
what else yet that is the update there
but when did this drop like what she was
found just dropped right now like I had
an article set up for when she was
missing but when I came in today it
updated that she was found under a
bridge one hour ago Texas A&M reporter
goes missing over the weekend found on
harmed but nothing seems fine so
hospital for evaluation
I'm sure they'll do like a press release
later mm-hmm sometimes that chick fila
make you a crazy bro you're gonna have
those those fries those waffle cup fries
go bonkers yeah the chick fila right
this all right mad go crazy don't put
your hand on me like that
don't give me a [ __ ] you ever had them
20-piece mcgee don't give me a face wag
like that face way go
face whack me man basically I don't play
a face whack me cuz my hands always here
protecting my face that's gin how is
nature update on the lady I went missing
perfectly fine though how is that a
Oprah thing did did you feel any like
effect from there when you're at the
Golden Globe Golden Globes you realize
how big a deal Oprah is when all the
a-listers are like old [ __ ]
Oprah like when she walked by the broom
with style yeah like it's Oprah Winfrey
she's so powerful man she could run for
president that's not right and and
technically win her two closest friends
say she's tonight or sorry last night
was kind of her way of being like it's
happening Wow it's not a baby see the
rock watching her perform it to you like
jaws open yeah you see Oprah Winfrey
talk and you realize you want to be VP
now you saw about run for it did I
Oprah's just got what eight just
powerful and just unicorn of a woman I
would I think about it if you had a
speech right and you know what the night
represents and you have so much waning
and everyone's like come on it to
inspire us deliver and you're like I
like to chill let me do my thing and
then you just dick it just be murdered I
got a listen to it I didn't listen to it
nine minutes long nine minutes and it's
so powerful and she just knocked it out
the park
it's like oh not only did I think she
was gonna deliver but she even more so
why why because she's she's just so and
she's a phenomenal actress as well or
because she decided to take her platform
which was her talk show and actually
have spread education The Oprah The
Oprah book club that I mean this is a
human being with insane and about it
says it has to delete tweet welcoming
our president Oprah I mean scroll down
nothing about respect for our future
president and that's NBC yeah they had
to delete it and then that's their
reasoning right there which they always
say this kind of stuff right third party
did it someone that wasn't supposed to
tweet tweeted it yeah that's hilarious
we know what you meant NBC I relaxed
Henny see it's all fine I don't give a
[ __ ]
two of
close friends that's exactly thinking
about it I just feel like well I don't
know that that Trump is it you know
sluggers get involved but I feel like
Oprah's too smart to run for president
she doesn't want that mess cuz her life
is so big she's fairly she's unifying
like something about oceans she met it's
all those white housewives and everybody
else and she's she's I when I think
about Oprah I think of her as I think of
a fair person I think of a thoughtful
fair human being if you know what she
standard met anyone who doesn't like
Oprah know outsides a racist and I don't
even know where she sits on the
political spectrum but I my feeling is
that she's such fair she's such an
effective smart man trust she's good at
everything that she's ever I trust her
she never failed I try to feel like
she's not gonna [ __ ] us over if she's
president me too it's a weird world it's
a weird world but I think she's
eminently I mean it's gonna sound like a
shock but I think she's just as capable
as you know I mean ah yeah she doesn't
come from the same rich background she
get the same playing bees not even that
she's just a she's just a very powerful
force of nature she just is everything
she touch with everything she touches
and generous moving this nation generous
is a [ __ ]
hell yeah the Oprah effect it's called
the Oprah effect yeah I start to feel
about it yeah so how about her man
Stedman just doing the damn thing just
the ultimate side yeah - I was that with
the mustache the drunk man the guy you
always hero
you talked about the black version dr.
Phil uh-huh yeah yeah and we talked
about the I've done say is he a doctor
what does he do he sucks on Oprah's
titty sir that's what he gets paid very
handsomely for it he's just he's a
handsome dude he's just heard he's
talking to Phil but tan he just he just
look who's talking
but ten they're exactly the same but
what's he do he is both deep and Oprah
Winfrey sir that's a where he [ __ ] up
how he'll never what six inches tall
yeah dr. Phil six six two and a dick on
him anyways how do you know Stedman
Stedman this will I do if I'd Stedman I
would steal that birth control and get
Oprah
pregnant huh I'm not saying that should
be his plan played college basketball at
hardin-simmons don't know that college
but very low level all right uh let's
see he's wrote some peas wrote some
books some self-help books how to make
it with Oprah okay how to hold down when
you're dating the most powerful woman on
earth by Stedman how to please over him
every way possible with Stedman how to
be Oprah's uber by Stedman alright so he
had his own kind of self-help thing
before Oprah yeah you can make it higher
up that ship form how long they've been
together bro for app for literally ready
yeah forever is that right about sixty
years sir okay so day one how long have
they been together what a powerful man
[Music]
five fast five fast facts click on that
you need to know one grand believe he
had not had ever married Oprah they
would not still be together
not true used to make that work keep
they're not married no you know I'm
saying though to he's a proud father and
grandfather don't care keep going three
Graham teaches everyone from world
leaders of small business how to develop
a personal identity off you [ __ ]
right you've got to create a personal ID
any cuz you got this shadow of the oh
well now you got to create your personal
identity alright you don't be known as
Oprah's man you don't mean no Winfrey
Zack step by the clam Graham was like an
old shoe to Oprah and never saw any PDA
between the couple hmm he gives her back
massages that's what that means
yeah they might just be best friends oh
well he served in the US Army played
professional basketball in Europe oh
cool so five useless [ __ ] factor here
okay Graham also loves seafood I don't
care how long have they been together
man he loves seafood it's great five
glorious facts that's fine he prefers
New Balances thirty years Oh [ __ ]
question bro
yeah forever I did not know that I read
so he's been that things have been
pretty good ever a lot of people thought
Oprah and her friend Gayle were rubbing
tits
if I had to do it over again something
happens with my wife because [ __ ] off
amaze me I'm go after Oprah I'm gonna
[ __ ] you don't know I can't complete six
yeah I'm too light in the ass for Oprah
but I'm gonna find myself a little break
I'm gonna get myself a second hair
transplant maybe get my face tighten a
little bit and do that get out go after
it and I'm gonna go :
I'm gonna call Ellen she's gay I hope we
Colin nope I'm gonna comb the Beverly
Hills Polo Club the next Oprah for all
the divorcees the 40-something did my
little easy do all right no bro
yeah but I'm married buddy I know but
you will have to do it tire and wear
robes a lot now listen you ain't [ __ ]
unless you're Stedman level you know
what that man's life is like mmm I mean
yeah is it a bummer is that awesome IIIi
think it's probably awesome I probably
he probably loves the [ __ ] everybody
loves me too kind of loves taking a back
seat buddy my daddy loves when they take
the harley-davidson out he's in a little
sidecar I bet he [ __ ] loves sir Sir
you are Troy I bet he never speaks where
they go on vacation
dick might be bigger than than I am so
doesn't matter I'm just saying he
doesn't matter she's on Oprah's died all
the [ __ ] time he can't have any of his
own do I bet he loves that they have
salmon every [ __ ] night I'm taking
care of business
bye take care of business means boom the
laundry no sir you might be taking care
of business I go to me and it means he
died in Oprah's
he's our King and he goes Oprah I know
that the world thinks you're amazing
get in the bedroom now cuz I'm hungry oh
you talking about you talking about
Fifty Shades Oprah now that's exactly
right
oh I think Stedman might lay it down you
talking about a six foot six ex-military
so a little respect sir two years next
military professional athlete for sure
however did you know he writes in the
bad a [ __ ] most I know he rides in
the
back she might show him around no she
goes [ __ ] in the back I'm driving
where we going don't worry about it you
know you're going you can see won't get
there that's how it's going you can see
when we get there oh man you know I'm
not hungry
well I am bit baby we had Mexican three
days a row you now 42 this gift for days
turn around side yeah just great
Ronettes Laughlin steady Jeff we've had
if we bet Mexican three days row Oh
Brooke we on for Ted yeah she goes I
guess she goes oh yeah she know what you
say and he was nothing nobody said
nothing big guys for a second does sound
like you you you you're talking back
yeah I know you have the enchilada again
yeah four days ago I guess what you know
talk like more you sleeping the Dutch
and again yeah that's two weeks for now
stay he goes like this sorry
you [ __ ] one why'd you [ __ ] write
and get it out just like you up the bed
girl in [ __ ] no she gets out goes to
the Mexican restaurant he gets as you
know I thought you'd want to eat tonight
you stayed a bad you stayed you know
what you staying here warm the car one
in the car I'll have my assistant bring
the refried beans you eaten tonight yeah
and she just she just dumped so [ __ ]
instead instead I did apartment Oh
[ __ ] he has seen a huge bowl of
refried beans yeah
oh you talk about the Oprah challenge so
he's this no bridge owns and then they
sit in the car did she go detention if
you fed no words this is what she does
she's not mad Oprah challenge inferior
man you got to sit in a hot car no he's
seeing that black Lincoln Navigator
huge bowl of refight beans but smash
she's on top she delivers him goes I
dare you not to finish this and then I
double dare you to fart in my house I'd
read this and then I [ __ ] dearest and
he's
shut the [ __ ] up you know with your
hands get in the bedroom right now she's
right behind him and what's this what
now get on the covers now and get on
covers now you gotta sleep if dear you
Dutch up in this thing if there is a
little peep out your butt I'd wear a
quark if I were you put the cork in put
the cork in otherwise might tell me so
two weeks two weeks you know are you
going oh [ __ ] she rewards him with a
long fart breathe that in go sleep let
me sleep - whistle [ __ ] and guess what
tomorrow you're doing the same [ __ ]
thing and maybe you talk about your
[ __ ] college basketball days all
right let's just the [ __ ] ously she'll
come in and shut our whole podcast down
[Laughter]
what happened oh I'll pretend like
you're content kids hanging from a
bridge like what happened she did leave
something for you in the lobby just a
bullet and cork - corks - of course I do
you know what to do
you don't did you and I didn't mention
this horse on our butt crying you time I
dumped her challenge we eat a bunch of
beans trying to at the fire well boys I
gotta fart so you guys are gonna breathe
in your [ __ ] heads oh that's that Oprah
challenge I couldn't do it for 30 years
she might be the next medicine the man
deserves a goddamn crown yes he does
keep it up stead we're room for a man
hold that hold that farting brother Wow
what else here to fascinate that's
pretty much it that was interesting
well well there we are
hope you guys learned a lot I hope
you'll enjoy love you to try the Stedman
Oprah challenge oh yeah you read you a
nice side of refried beans I mean I've
worked out for you you kids you're gonna
be listening to this and if you're
anywhere near Nashville
Nashville Tennessee throw refried beans
up on you don't you come see Brian at
Zanies
day that's the January 11 12 13 and then
that's this week right B yeah this week
Brian's and Naturals Amy yeah Columbus
Ohio January 25 26 27 and then DC improv
which wasn't on the website my bad DCM
proper one two three DCM broth come see
me this week I'm in Portland brother
you're in Portland Portland man when do
you leave Thursday
no [ __ ] Thursday Friday Saturday yeah we
wouldn't brother doing it on the road by
doing the damn thing hopefully my neck
and your tummy hold up yeah bring
refried beans let's do the Oprah
challenge Portland I'll be there look
forward to seeing you guys all shows are
almost sold out once she'll Thursday 2
shows Friday to show Saturday when I'm
back in town on Sunday might do a little
fight campaign Saturday night with Rogan
sorry for the fights Jeremy Stephens
bringing zombie duo Choi do ho Choi
crazy Superboy Superboy that's right all
right we're back is that pretty boy is
that the guy who father looks so Swanson
yeah so we might do that yeah get back
in time okay
or if we don't die in Nashville not
Davenport yeah so I'm in Portland
Thursday Friday Saturday you tickets
right now next show then is Boston that
[ __ ] is sold out that's the big one and
then after that Oh Denver there are 10
tickets left for the Thursday night show
we're think about adding another show on
Wednesday night I will keep you guys
posted but Denver is almost sold out in
favorite first second third I'm in st.
Louis st. Louis get tickets now teef at
kake.com for Brian and myself thank you
guys for buying the beefs about her
theme tease those [ __ ] are sold out
yes when I do it we might need to do
Oprah challenge t I don't my figured out
I'm ready but your beans funny [ __ ] yes
Overtown challenge
t back a Portland Nashville Brian myself
get your tickets son yes who's the fire
kid we're out